okay so happiness equation happiness is
greater than or equal to events minus
expectations
um
so
one
one i guess issue with this idea issue
in inverted commas that i've never quite
been able to square is
the response of
does that therefore mean that we should
just have low expectations for
everything in life and you know always
think of life with a slightly
pessimistic outlook so that whatever
happens then life's it's a surprise and
it's a good thing
and when people say that to me i kind of
think yes yeah yes asterisks well i
don't know what the asterisk is if if
you if your if your target in life is to
be happy yeah okay honestly then yeah
lower expectations will make you happier
okay so you know if you know if you if
you basically tell yourself i know i
know many friends in my life that
decided that they've had enough of life
uh you know the fast-paced lives they
went and lived in the dominican republic
and the only thing that would make them
unhappy on a day is that there is not
enough wind to kitesurf
okay and they make enough money to live
a very simple life and they want to kite
surf that's it their expectations are
very low
they don't expect a ferrari they don't
expect to be able to live in a big city
they don't want to go to museums
expectations are low and apply that to
anything now you go to india and if you
know many many people hundreds of
millions of people don't expect to eat
today give them a bowl of rice and
they're very happy so if your target is
happiness
yeah that's the way to go
okay if your target is success and
impact on life however you need to go to
the art you go you need to go the
opposite way okay and the opposite way
is i need ambition so so you know when i
wrote solve for happy at the beginning i
wrote it with the mission of 10 million
happy yeah and then 10 million happy
happened very quickly and my team
got together and said maybe we should
set a bigger target so we didn't set 11
we didn't set a hundred million is that
a billion happy
now a billion happy is a crazy target to
have how many people in the world have
reached a billion people right
but it's a nice ambitious
uh a target to aspire to so when i wake
up in the morning uh year one when we've
you know we've achieved another 10
million or so
i don't tell myself that's it we've
achieved we're done yeah i say to myself
there is still way to go there is still
more to do okay but now so you're stuck
between those two
extents if you want one that says have
no expectation at all and you'll be
happy and the other is says have
extremely high expectations and you'll
be successful what's the problem with
the modern world is that we believed in
this and not that but you know the
problem with the modern world is when
you're growing up i i'm sure i don't
know your mom but your mom told you
success is more important than happiness
go thrive in life success leads to
happiness or that success leads to
happiness right so we believe that yeah
well it's not true i mean how often do
you meet someone who's successful and
rich and famous and swimming in money
and everyone's attracted to them and
paparazzis are all around them and
they're miserable okay success doesn't
always lead to happiness now
between those two
there is a midpoint like everything in
life which is
i need a realistic expectation a
realistic expectation is not lowered
than how it should be and it's not
higher than how it should be i need an
ambitious
ambition that is higher than the
realistic expectation and i need a
contentment that sometimes my even my
realistic expectation might be missed
okay and in that case
while i aim for a realistic expectation
yeah and a high ambition yep i'm getting
the best of both worlds yes i'm trying
to be successful and at the same time
i'm contented as i go through that path
when life misses my expectations
sometimes oh
sick okay this is nice so i have this
dilemma when it comes to the book that
i'm working on um which is
the dilemma of
uh what is what should what should be my
ambition for the book
uh
when it comes to writing one of the
classic accolades is hitting the new
york times bestseller list and so i have
this as a very clear thing like okay if
i was being quite ambitious about this i
would be like hey i want the book to be
a new york times bestseller
but there's something about that that
like when i sit down to write it
in a way it doesn't it doesn't feel good
it doesn't feel if it feels like almost
demotivating because that's a thing
that's outside of my control
whereas when i think of it as
the objective of this book is
i want to write a book i'm proud of and
i want to enjoy the journey along the
way
that's a very kind of contentment type
goal rather than an ambitious type goal
i think and when i lean towards that
then i feel oh it's all good i feel the
parasympathetic
kind of activation rather than the
sympathetic activation which is what i
feel for the more ambitious goal
now i think this is great because then i
can optimize for happiness and just
write the book that i want but then part
of me wonders that like
is am i missing something but not going
for a more ambitious goal by not putting
a number on saying i want to get a
million sales i want to get three
million sales because sales translates
to impact on the one hand but also more
money and all of the other selfish
desires on the other hand
any any thoughts about that particular
lots of thoughts okay so i want to cover
this in if you'll allow me in two layers
fantastic so layer one
is a a very very important definition
okay
uh you know we're video gamers so i i
always say life is like a video game and
we can come back to that conversation in
a minute
but if life
is a game
there are two types of games that are
defined one is an infinite game and the
other is a finite game a finite game is
a game where there is a target a
destination and a win
okay an infinite game is like pac-man
have you ever checked your score when
you were playing pac-man you don't know
the purpose of pac-man was to play
pac-man for as long as you're playing
pac-man okay and then sometimes you you
know you lose and then you play again
you know there is there is no
very very few people who are trying to
be world champions on on pac-man and so
they were monitoring the score
life is an infinite game because the the
the finite bit of it is when you die and
you're no longer playing that's it so as
long as you're in this game
your target is what is to play
interestingly it's not to achieve
anything so the most interesting
part of life is
for most of us who are highly engaged in
the modern world
if you remove the target
suddenly everything becomes okay
everything becomes so enjoyable yeah i
write
honestly ali i write to write hey
friends thank you so much for watching
if you enjoyed this clip then click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day